myforstatter is celebrating what she
says
is a huge victory a judge declaring her
beliefs
worthy of respect even if they are
offensive to some people
especially those in the trans community
people can wear what they want and call
themselves what they want
but they can't change sex maya says
stating this
cost her an employment contract so she
went to a tribunal
that sided with her old bosses she
appealed
and now a judge has said maya should not
be discriminated against for expressing
her opinions on sex and gender
i think this case is going to have
really wide repercussions
it's going to improve the state of the
debate
because it says that disagreement is not
harassment
people can have different views and we
ought to be able to talk about them
maya has high profile support from the
author jk rowling
for stating as she puts it that sex is
real
but jane fay a trans rights campaigner
worries what this judgment could lead to
what she shouldn't be allowed to do is
to go around
using that belief of throwing that
belief in the face of the people in such
a way that
it causes upset to them it's not just
trans people who should be scared of
that
it is every minority in the country
women
scared that um black people will be
scared
people with disability the company i
worked for are also concerned
in a statement they said this decision
is disappointing and surprising
because we believe judge taylor got it
right when he found this type of
offensive speech
causes harm to trans people and
therefore could not be protected
under the equality act the judge made
clear his ruling on maya's case doesn't
mean
trans people can be discriminated
against or harassed
but one woman's right to speak out on
this particular issue
could have wide-ranging implications for
others who want to talk about
controversial
and divisive topics freely becky
cottrell
sky news